the boggarts or the Bogart is a
malevolent theory of spirit that
originates from English folklore they
often appear in households causing
objects to disappear foods to sour and
even disturbing your pets their
appearance varies throughout different
folklore many describe them as
human-like often very ugly of some
beasts your attributes others describe
them as almost gremlin or goblin like
some boggarts are even able to take the
form of various animals and more fearful
creatures much like the Boggart shown in
the Harry Potter franchise who is able
to take the form of whatever the
beholder fears most the only way shown
to defeat this type of bugger is with
laughter
the majority of Bogaerts tend to live
outdoors in the marshland often found in
dark and damp places such as holes in
the ground and underneath bridges when a
person had gone missing in the marsh
they will assume to have been caught by
a boggart and most likely eaten the
marshland boggarts were known to abduct
children and were often associated with
evil doing the household Bogert would
rarely cause harm to the family chairs
residents with however if they choose to
flee it will follow them and continue to
cause mischief they have been known to
crawl into people's beds during the
evening and place a hand on their face
even strip their bed sheets from them
it's believed that hanging a horseshoe
on the door or leaving a pile of salt
outside your bedroom will keep the ball
out away a brownie is a type of boggarts
that you may have seen before
unknowingly in JK Rowling's Harry Potter
the basis of the house elves is derived
from folklore on brownies the brownie is
a good-natured house fairy that has been
known to perform odd jobs around the
house such as cleaning sewing and
cooking often only making an appearance
during the evening as the brownie does
not like to be disturbed while working
they usually wear no clothes but they
have been seen in brown rags very
similar to those of Dobby
despite their good nature if a brownie
is provoked or angered they will become
a Bhagat given a brownie honey once they
become a Bhagat is said to calm them and
allow them to return to their natural
state in some folklore it states that if
you make the creature a new suit and
they wear it they will vanish forever
and never be seen or heard from again
this seems to be where JK Rowling had
her idea of Harry given Dobby the sock
in order to release him from the Malfoy
family like most bogus brownies are said
to be invisible to anyone who doesn't
possess the second sight buckets are
such interesting creatures because
they're depicted in so many different
manners their surroundings determine
what type of creature they become a
helpful hand around the house can
quickly turn into a mischievous and even
evil spirit if the wrong thing is said
or done if you've enjoyed this video
then please go ahead and leave it a like
consider subscribing if folklore
mythology is something that interests
you if you have anything you'd like to
discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please go ahead
and let me know in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology and
folklore explained
[Music]